>> Now of course, some of us do see this as a 3D shape.
You can think of this as a paper folded here. One plane of the paper and
another plane of the paper. This looks kind of like an open book.
This particular line here then can be ignored, just being a line of these two
planes, not signifying a surface by itself. If you view this only as a line,
and not signifying a surface then it adverses David's first problem.
But how do we address David's second problem of this being a fold or
a blade depending upon where we started constraint propagation from? The answer
is that we actually have a much more complex ontology of disconnections.
The answer lies in the fact that we have so far used a very simple ontology,
just to demonstrate the constraint propagation process. In reality the ontology
risk constraints is more complicated. Let's do Y-constraint may not just fold,
fold and fold, but it might also be blade, blade and blade.
And the L-constraint is not always blade and blade and fold and fold.
It could also be blade and fold and fold and blade. Now we can see
David's second problem disappearing, because the Y junction may have a blade and
the L junction may also suggest a blade. And there is then no conflict. Let me
know that what we have shown here, is still not a full anthology of the Y, W,
L and T constraints. T constraints in particular, may have additional
complexity. The advantage of having a more complete ontology is, that we can
use that ontology to interpret more complex scenes like this one, where there
are two rectangular objects, one being partially occluded by the other one.
Of course, the more complicated ontology is not without its own problems.
It now introduces ambiguities of a different kind. This particular junction.
Is it now a blade, blade, blade, or is it a fold, fold,
fold? Both of them are permissible in the new complete ontology. In order to
resolve some of these ambiguities, we can come up with additional conventions.
One convention is, that all of these edges that are next to the background,
we'll consider them to be blades. So we'll make this a blade,
blade, blade, blade. Once you make all these blades, then it's easy to
propagate the constraints. Notice this W junction could have been a fold, blade,
fold, or a blade, fold, blade. But if we adopt the convention of labeling
all of these lines as blades, then, this W junction can only be blade, fold,
blade. But if this is a fold, this Y junction can only be fold, fold, fold, and
so on. And yet, helps us resolve the ambiguity of what this junction could be.
This task of image interpretation is an instance of the abduction task.
In abduction, we try to come up with the best explanation for the data.
This is the data, we're trying to interpret it in terms of an explanation.
We'll discuss abduction in more detail when we come to diagnosis. Well
now notice that, we start with what we know. Blade, blade, blade. And that we
propagate the constraints, so that we can disambiguate between other junctions.